this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
thank you for joining us i'm kirsten
joyce breaking this afternoon a woman is
dead after police say her son stabbed
her to death inside an east valley
apartment this happened around 11 a.m
near nellis and vegas valley that's
where we find 8 news now investigator
david charns live with the very latest
david
yeah so kirsten here's what we know
right now police just wrapping up a news
conference giving us some information
about this this happened in this
apartment complex behind me near where
we are on vegas valley and nellis around
11 this morning a family member called
police saying his brother was acting odd
and there was some sort of argument with
their mother inside swat was called in
and then a bit later the suspect the
victim's son
came out of an apartment here covered in
blood and armed with knives right now
police are processing an apartment here
behind me a crime scene and they say
they will be here doing that throughout
the night and the coroner will also be
here to identify this woman who we only
know is a woman who is about 70 years of
age obviously the mother of two adult
sons at this point we do not know a
motive again that suspect who is
believed to be the victim's son is in
custody here
in custody with police and will be
interviewed by police to try to figure
out exactly why this happened but again
an adult son accused of killing his
mother in her 70s we are live near vegas
valley and nellis i'm david charns 8
news now
thank you very much david this is a
developing story stay with 8 news now on
air and online for the latest